a high school senior in Utah was the
subject to public shaming a lot of it
from across the country because of the
dress that she wore to prom watch a
single post with a one-word caption and
four photos
changed everything I was accused of
racism cultural appropriation I didn't
mean any harm or racist intent that's
cuz I had Dom and the dress she wore is
called a chai Pao it is commonly worn in
China in response to the photos Twitter
user Jeremy Lamb tweeted this quote my
culture is not your bleeping prom dress
whatever that means but his tweet
received almost a hundred and eighty
thousand likes ironically the tripod
isn't actually from China originally it
was appropriated from a neighboring non
Chinese culture but whatever details
don't matter in 2018 Kathy aru is
founding publisher of Catalina magazine
and she is of course our liberal Sherpa
guiding us through the labyrinth of this
modern world sir Kathy it's great to see
you thank you for coming on this raises
look I get it she in unintentionally but
still appropriated a cultural talisman
from a culture that's not hers but does
this go both ways does this mean that I
mean Chinese people are wearing neckties
which is a Western invention are they
committing cultural appropriation by
doing that well at what she did it's
almost like an exploitation of a culture
she's exploiting it it's appropriation
because she is taking advantage of a
culture she doesn't really know much
about I don't think a businessman a
Chinese businessman doesn't understand
the Western culture he understands what
the Thai is he understands what the suit
is but she had no idea what this dress
meant and what it's about and she didn't
even appreciate it one of her one of her
comments was it's just the effing dress
I mean this is a culture she borrowed a
culture and she cared so little to
appreciate it
so definitely to show you if she had
loved the dress more would it have been
better she loved the dress she knew so
little about the background she said she
loved it because it would give her
attention she loved the attention it
would give her and then she took those
pictures in these poses that were
I think she thought were agent poses but
they were actually vapenation and
promoting some youtuber that is
controversial in itself and she's
praying to Papa John's Pizza that's what
that pose is so that wasn't a pose that
is appreciating a culture the supposed
mocking a culture and promoting a
YouTube Papa John's culture it's a it's
a YouTube you won't know so but okay so
but what about I mean this is not the
only form of cultural appropriation from
China and people use chopsticks the
Chinese food college students have
Chinese characters whose meaning they
don't know tattooed on their bodies or
all of those out of bounds now - well
well the Beijing appropriation is an
appreciation is a fine line and it seems
like unist well apparently she didn't
understand that she she maybe is not a
racist but what she did 180 a form of
racism show me so watch what you're
saying is that white people ought to
stick just to white culture and
celebrate white culture no I'm getting
confused because I thought you're saying
that white people should stay in their
Lane and just stick with white culture
and celebrate it their own culture right
is that what you're saying she clearly
used this for personal gain she wanted
the attention she was in the middle of
all those photos she wanted it for
personal gain she put it on Twitter on
Facebook it was for attention it wasn't
like eating Chinese food and enjoying
the delicious people of people actually
wear dresses for attention I mean that's
sort of what they are so um I wonder
though just I mean what about people
from other cultures from Asian cultures
who dyed their hair blonde but don't
fully understand the culture of
blondness is that cultural appropriation
they understand and they're appreciating
it it's not a majority culture taking
advantage of a minority culture it's not
someone dipping into a culture and
globally gain I mean white Americans are
a tiny percentage of global culture of
course they did invent the air but this
is a joy so let me ask you I mean
she's there do any culture she's there
here people from elsewhere I don't know
she's mocking sure this does raise an
interesting question though about about
assimilation
so assimilation which we've thought for
hundreds of years was a good thing is
the process of cultural appropriation I
come in and I take parts of your culture
and make them my own I adopt your
culture well we thought that was good
but now the idea is that everyone stays
in their own culture and then of course
by definition hates every other culture
assimilation and there's appropriation
and she didn't do this to assimilate to
get to know what culture she did it to
just enjoy it for an evening get as much
Fame and publicity out of it or she
could on Twitter and Facebook and social
media and just step right out so let me
ask you this when somebody from when
someone from Dubai flies on an airplane
which was of course invented by the
Wright brothers at Kitty Hawk all right
why isn't that an even more effect and
just gets on the plane and has a glass
of champagne and doesn't think about the
contribution of these ohio brothers to
flight
that's not cultural appropriation but I
don't think that they're getting
anything they're not hurting anyone and
they're not offending anyone by doing so
and when she put on that dress she hurt
and offended others attention she really
hurt them she maybe she should go to
prison we're gonna discuss that next
week Kathy Ruth thank you